foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I think Florio was a lawyer when we
first started 15 years ago you were is
that right you were a lawyer you weren't
even in this business 15 years ago I was
in the business I was practicing law and
I was in the business you started
inviting me on foolishly about 15 years
or so ago and I remember when you left
the mothership fritzy would invite me on
and I still didn't quite understand why
but yeah I was doing both jobs kind of
full time until NBC came along in 2009
and that's when I escaped a practice of
law forever he's Mike Florio he runs the
website pro football talk also pro
football talk live with Chris Sims that
precedes our show on the program all
right recap the week what has stood out
so far since Sunday's games Monday's
games
well I know what stood out to me it's
not standing out to the NFL the NFL
players Association but Dan we're still
in the aftermath of this to talk about
low situation and we were horrified by
what we saw on Thursday night we were
stupefied by what we saw the prior
Sunday and then Sunday night Cameron
bray to the Buccaneers slams his head
into Chris Godwin lands on the ground
struggles to his feet runs off the field
two plays later he's back in maybe three
however many plays it was he's back in
without ever being checked for a
concussion they check him at halftime
he's got a concussion he's out for the
game and the League's position and the
Union's position is the spotters who
were paid to be monitoring the activity
believe that Cameron Bright clearly hit
his shoulder not his head
our Lying Eyes would say otherwise and
it's amazing to me that of all the times
that the NFL should be as buttoned up as
it could be when it comes to flagging
potential concussions it would be in the
first Prime Time game played after the
Prime Time game in which we were
horrified by the site of tuatangawaloa
in the fencing posture and stretch it
off the field and Dan what's going to
happen is it's getting brushed under the
rug it's all going away but it's a sign
that there are real issues still with
the NFL's concussion protocol maybe
issues they can never fix but this one
is not going to be
given any time of day they don't want
any more heat in a hot kitchen they're
already dealing with enough with tour
they're just going to pretend this thing
didn't happen even though it did that is
amazing to me and they're in a damn
thing we can do about it other than say
this is amazing I can't believe they're
doing and I was told yesterday that now
they're going to go the opposite there's
going to be an overreaction over
correction with protocol that is going
to happen uh probably later this week
and also you know the Dolphin's doctor
is not checking to it for the concussion
he's checking him for the back so the
neurologist paid the price by saying hey
doesn't have a concussion you know the
Dolphin's doctor got off here like all
right you checked him for his back which
is supposed to be the reason why he
stumbled a couple of times and then you
put him back into the game it felt like
somebody had to pay the price this
unnamed neurologist because I was told
that the NFL didn't want to embarrass
him by mentioning his name that he lost
his job but that's sort of what's
playing out here uh and will over the
next day or two
that's right and we should be getting
some sort of an answer we've been
promised transparency now how accurate
will the information be I don't know and
Dan one of the big questions is whether
or not anybody even looked at the video
of tuatanga vailoa stumbling and being
held up by a teammate the protocol
requires the doctors to review the video
I can't get anyone to tell me with any
degree of certainty that they actually
did and as I've said this and written it
no one has contacted me and said hey
you're barking up the wrong tree here
and trust me they're not bashful about
telling me that if they think I'm
barking up the wrong tree nobody has
said you should quit talking about the
possibility they didn't watch the video
but how astounding would that be and Dan
here's what I think it all comes back to
and this is going to piss people off at
345 Park Avenue but I think this is the
fundamental truth and this is why
Cameron Bright is being swept under the
rug you got an existential threat to the
game here as it relates to the supply of
young football players and if I'm a
parent with a kid playing High School
football and I'm watching these NFL
games and I say even this
state-of-the-art structure sure for
protecting players doesn't work how can
I expect a local high school sports
conference to protect my son and get him
out of the game when he's banged his
head if the NFL can't do it when Cameron
Bright bangs his head with 22 million
people watching and 22 million people
seeing it how can I ever fully trust
that my son is safe on a football field
and I just thank God my sons at the age
where I don't have to run that analysis
through my brain right now because I'm
not sure what the end result would be
yeah but you have the players are going
to continue to lie to stay in the game
Dan orlovsky was with us and yesterday
and he said yeah if I was 24 I'd be
lying Drew Brees said I lied all the
time I'd even lie to my wife
uh what's Tua saying when he goes to the
sidelines he's probably saying my back
you know he didn't want to come out of
the game
so how do you get players to understand
how can we protect you if you don't help
us protect you well but they're never
going to there's only a small handful of
players who have the luxury of tapping
out and not worrying about their job I
remember when Ben Roethlisberger did it
in a Steelers game in Pittsburgh seven
eight years ago he was heralded for
doing the selfless thing that was for
the good of the game yeah because you
she doesn't have to worry about getting
Wally pipped everybody else has to worry
about that and especially to him in a
year where he's got to prove not just
ability but durability and that's the
other thing that doesn't get discussed
here with Tua he's got an obligation to
protect himself on a football field Drew
Brees protected himself the smaller
quarterbacks I remember the first time I
was ever at an NFL related function and
guys like Dan Marino and Boomer Esiason
there it's like holy crap where's the
Beanstalk like these guys are huge
they're Giants and Drew Brees normal
size Russell Wilson normal size tour
normal size you got to get rid of the
ball you got to avoid getting Ragdoll
you know that hit 6'5 guy isn't going to
go down the way that tuo went down on
Thursday night a guy who's 6-1 which
means he's 5-11 190 which means he's
175. he's going down in a very violent
way so that's part of it too but that
makes it all the more important Dan
because we know we're not going to get
the truth from the players the structure
has to be in place where it accepts
we're never gonna get the truth from the
players we can have another way to find
out what's really going on inside their
heads after they take an impact to the
skull he's Mike Florio from pro football
talk the report came out from the New
York Post which is owned by the Murdoch
family and they own Fox and Tom Brady is
employed by Fox so they've got the
information that they've been reporting
about Tom Brady's marriage
um
is this is this fair game now
to talk to are you allowed to in a
sports setting talk to Brady about
what's going off the field
and and could that affect him on the
field
I wrote something about this a couple of
weeks ago because CNN got involved in
the Tom Brady personal life beat and
reported that Tom and Gisele were living
separately it's like CNN's reporting no
like what what kind of strange world is
this but when you're talking about
somebody who lives in an inherently
public life and he was asked about it
generally a few weeks ago does it bother
him and he understands you can't have it
both ways there are plenty of guys in
sports who have this attitude of hey
everybody look at me wait a minute what
the hell are you looking at you can't
have it both ways if you want that
attention and all the money that comes
from it and all the adulation and praise
you can't pick and choose what people
look at and Brady gets it and hey if
we're going to be obsessed over whether
or not his finger is affecting his
performance his shoulder is affecting
his performance and the guy disappeared
for 11 days of training camp but we
never got a straight answer why if
there's some turmoil in his personal
life that potentially affect his
performance that's relevant the
Buccaneers entire team had to go to
Miami last week and they all stayed in a
hotel with kids and pets it was like
Noah's Ark there and they lost the game
and Todd balls the head coach was saying
last night on the Buccaneers radio
network we couldn't focus so yeah
anything that keeps a guy from focusing
on the task at hand is fair game
especially when it's one of the highest
profile athletes slash celebrities
married to somebody who is extremely
high profile I think it does become fair
game and when the Murdoch family's
newspaper is reporting this when they're
ready to pay him 37.5 million a year I
think that does make it fair
yeah I was wondering about that because
there were members in our profession who
were critical of us prying into Tom
Brady's life I and I always go back to
Tiger Woods when tiger was whatever was
happening off the golf course until it
affected him on the golf course then I I
wasn't interested in that I I wanted to
be fair Brady missed practices now it
becomes something more than that
and I asked Brady about this months ago
when we were on a conference call and we
got to ask him a question and I asked
him about I was 50 when I decided to go
home I knew it was time to leave ESPN I
said you know you got to eventually go
home like when do you like that tug of
war that you and Gisele have
and he kind of pushed it off and said
well I don't know if they want me at
home all the time
but then he did answer it later and he
got a little emotional about it because
he's he's addicted
we all have addictions he's addicted to
football and his wife said
I want you to come home and he decided
to come back and play football here so
it's a real thing
it's just I don't know how forthcoming
he's going to be in a press conference
if they lose to the Falcons this weekend
is that fair game like it feels like the
door is open
can you ask him questions and still be
keeping them in a sports related manner
I think it's all fair game at this point
because he's already said he understands
it goes with the territory I don't know
that it's fair to ask him if he throws
three interceptions against the Falcons
is the fact that you and your wife have
hired divorce lawyers the reason for you
throwing three interceptions but I think
it's fair game for general questions in
his midweek press conference which
usually happens on Thursday and just for
analysis like hey this guy is dealing
with stuff that no NFL player has ever
dealt with he has stretched the rubber
band farther than anyone ever has the
tank is well below E everything with him
is unchartered Waters and we don't know
he doesn't know nobody knows where it
goes from here and it is fascinating and
you just can't look if you're going to
have this huge social media platform and
you're selling underwear and crypto how
in the world can you run and hide when
there's some big deal like this that
causes you to disappear for 11 days of
training camp and no one will explain
and they try to act like it was all
pre-planned and nobody believes it was
pre-planned it it's just a reality show
that is playing out for all of us to see
and it directly affects the performance
of the player which directly affects the
performance of the team and you got all
the DraftKings and FanDuel commercials
for people to bet and they're making
bets based upon how guys are going to
perform I think it is fair game to talk
about it and wonder how it's going to
affect it
Before I Let You Go
um
is there a coach that's on the hot suit
oh Matt rule
Matt rule will be lighting the yule log
[Laughter]
so a a rule instead of a yuletide it's a
a rule tide law how's he gonna last Dan
I think poor Baker Mayfield he made a
four and a half million dollar bet on
himself we love it when guys bet on
themselves because it's not our money
he made a four and a half million dollar
bet on himself all things told when he
took the trade to Carolina thinking he's
going to have the kind of year that sets
him up for a big contract
uh through four weeks he's got a lot of
work to do and you know when Ben
McAdoo's the offensive coordinator all
due respect I mean it's kind of hard to
find a good offensive coordinator when
the offensive coordinators who are being
considered know that everyone's job is
riding on this guy getting it done so
you're getting down to Choice five six
or seven Matt rule yeah I know he says
he's not concerned about it well maybe
he's not maybe he's past it because it
just feels like it's a matter of time
before David absolutely see you later
but can Nathaniel Hackett be on the hot
seat
this early in his coaching career well I
think that he could be one and done
every time a coach gets fired after one
year we've got a post at PFT that we
dust off and update to remind everybody
that it happens a lot more often than
you think you got new ownership that did
not hire him and we've seen some
fundamental flaws in game planning and
game execution decision making not
making decisions quickly enough making
bad decisions and these folks who come
from Walmart where they have put
together a multi-billion dollar company
a company that has like they've got like
everybody in that family is a
billionaire that's how much money this
company has made they're not going to
screw around Dan that in the time that I
have been explaining to you Nathaniel
hackett's status Walmart has made enough
money to finance his buyout and then
some they won't hesitate to say see you
later Nathaniel Hackett always great to
talk to you Mike thank you good talking
congratulations on the 15 years thank
you Mike Mike had the under by the way
he goes there's no way you last that 15
years the under was like
five months something like that six
months